so played we teammates yeah we go hijack
you are on my team you happy we're gonna
win they need to really concentrate on
this tiny map hmm the evidence points
towards a jar of pickles somewhere that
jar was moving there's an egg under the
couch is there what does an egg mean
okay don't worry about it man leave my
egg alone all righty then kids this guy
smoked one vape and he's dead he tried
Harold once and he died kill me that
door opened and closed did did you open
that no which one of you is the penis I
want to watch hey wait look at the wall
are you seeing the shadow the puppet
show it for you oh my god a little bit
find me a donut I need to have an
anatomical that's not gonna get this
video demonetised come on I need to
reach Nuala
yeah you need to go edgy here okay yeah
hello hi
I started become the cigarettes now I'm
stuck Wyckoff and jackie vape too hard
yeah dude
didn't you see the PSA man you can't do
that news guys
I don't think you can become the dick
it's gotta be possible that's why it
exists I never saw the penis I don't
know if I want to see alright I I've
screwed myself you don't know that 20 on
the time damn we'll catch it on the next
pass around you really you really can do
like a puppet show - wait
put your face shadow right there hey
wait wait the hole in the front of your
face looks kind of like the right shape
can you stand
can you look at the wall for me just
[Laughter]
like that how do you like that I gave
him the slip I gave him the slippy dip
[Laughter]
what
around mine everywhere what the I don't
even know where you Oh
broke the map are you what the [ __ ] are
you this I don't know where you are so I
use a can and the rafter I'm in the room
with the two couches with the dude
sitting opposite the one waiting yeah
I'm not a hundred percent sure what you
are but I know where you are but you
have to tell me how good my spy is I
haven't really good to win okay okay can
you see me I'm jumping oh I've got you
in the corner ah that's pretty I don't
know do you see this one up in the top
no I can't actually see you you sink
into the shelf
yeah right tiny sliver of Tobin room I
mean I guess it is technically visible
so whatever
Jack wins the win that's the deal
wait obey the rules that's a pretty Pro
spot
I like this hey can you guys become the
Taser wait for it yeah man yeah sir give
me one vape please could I hey vapes not
about Weed Man
it's not about weed I think he's been
smoking too much of the product yeah
excuse me haha
sir your head hey guys how's it going
we're dealing with so
I think I I think I know why he's not
really here cuz they've got a giant hole
in the front of his head there to begin
with
hey Paul brother no I don't think so we
can still save just got to get more
leads in them I guess wait no hang on
wait wait where's a okay wait I can save
your brother you can become the dick
wait can you oh my god wait assumed is
true for man with you don't point your
balls at me jokes huh what's the
difference between an erection and a dog
walk the dog you have to kill the dog
before you bury it
[Laughter]
that's a euphemism for sex right you
beriberi your bone or something so maybe
really just try to work in a kill on the
dog joke because I know how everyone's
gonna love that [ __ ] I've goofed real
bad no no I can't see I did it we'll
know if I find you I'm not gonna kill
you I'm just gonna tase you okay all
right okay all right then
no not unless I tase you first no time
to catch your face full of shotgun
everybody wants bread get the bread
there pickles Patrick I
yzma tell me Peter you got a Peter Eater
behind the toilet
ear on it are you horny Patrick
[Laughter]
[Music]
did they up the shotgun cuz holy [ __ ]
it's like you have to search I there's
how what could I give you that would not
just instantly give me away no no we got
this we can do this we can do this I
don't know about you but I'm a pro level
prop hunter I'm a level 10 prop hunter
mm-hmm do you have the goggles of seeing
I'm +10 against props that was for some
reason that was a turd inside one of
these end tables that I thought those
alright I am the same color as a turd
I'm not only one color but I am mostly
the same color as a turd but I'm not a
turd okay you know you don't [ __ ] me out
but you may be able to shatter me you
[ __ ]
I don't know no clues goddamn I was
sitting in the open you [ __ ] where
the [ __ ] am i oh I saw you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I saw you [ __ ] are we
we're in some kind of laundry chute with
a dead body is that a door wait yeah I
can't open it though can you open it the
hell are you oh my god you wait go over
there
wait I wanna I'm curious I'm curious
mark you're like a grilled cheese I am
bread like triangles and [ __ ] oh
yeah open this door because there's
nothing behind it yeah yeah if you could
just let me should just hang out with
our friends and oh did you let them by
yeah can't wait there we go perfect no
dick comeback I've got rotation lock
enabled there's no way he can find me it
it just won't work I see this dick let's
see let's see if we can
[Laughter]
blew my load all over this piece of
bread that money
[Music]